well a further royal breaking news the
metropolitan police have said that the
bbc journalist martin beshear
won't face action over claims that he
faked documents ahead of securing his
exclusive interview
with princess diana in 1995. for let's
go live for our client correspondent
martin brunt and martin remind us
what documents these were
they were allegedly fake bank documents
that um and the the allegation at the
time these aren't new allegations and
they
surfaced about a year after the 1995
uh interview um a shocking interview
with princess diana in which she
revealed
grim details of the state of her
marriage but the allegation was that
martin bashir the interviewer for
bbc's panorama had used fake
bank documents to gain access to diana
by showing them to her brother earl
spencer
and persuading him that
royal household employees were being
paid by the security service to spy
on princess diana the allegation was
that
these documents were used to persuade
earl spencer
to give bashir access to princess diana
and months later he secured that rather
devastating
interview now the allegations were made
soon after the interview the bbc
had an investigation and it doesn't
appear to have
resulted in in much action certainly
none that was publicized
but the allegations came up again last
year in a couple of
tv documentaries and they included an
interview with a graphic designer
who said that he had been commissioned
by
martin bashir to create the false
documents
and that led to an outcry in december
the commission of the metropolitan
police
said that an investigation hadn't been
started
by scotland yard because they simply
hadn't had
a formal complaint but in january
a couple of months ago they did get a
formal complaint it's thought from earl
spencer's former
head of security and at that point so
within the last two months scotland yard
started
what they call an assessment of the
information that they were given
uh it wasn't a formal investigation it
was an assessment that's
how police describe these sort of
pre-investigation activities these days
anyway today scotland has said it's not
going to launch
a full investigation and it's a brief
statement from scotland yard
commander alex murray has said that the
yard had received correspondence
alleging unlawful activity um in
connection with the documentary in 1995.
i think the allegation must have been a
fraud um
forging the documents um
commander murray goes on to say this was
carefully assessed by specialist
detectives
they obtained legal advice from
metropolitan police lawyers independent
council
and from the cps the crown prosecutors
but following a detailed assessment says
the commander
and in view of the advice we received
we've determined
it's not appropriate to begin a criminal
investigation
no further action will be taken he says
but
he does add that is as in any other
matter
should any significant new evidence come
to light
we will assess it um i understand that
um this exercise to date has simply been
an assessment not an investigation and
nobody
i understand it has been interviewed in
any way
as a potential suspect or as a as a
witness
to date and that according to scotland
yard is as far
as this is going to go uh the bbc of
course
um having had an original internal
investigation
in 1996 that we think went nowhere
has launched late last year a new
investigation headed by lord dyson
and the bbc says it is determined to get
to the bottom
of whatever happened what was done to
secure the princess's interview